31 de marzo de 2021 a la corte penal
internacional confirmó la decisión de
absolver a logan van gogh de crímenes
contra la humanidad la sala de
apelaciones revoca todas las condiciones
restantes para la liberación de bajó
tras esta sentencia
aunque lo que está en el centro del
procedimiento judicial que comenzó en
enero de 2016 es el conflicto entre los
dos políticos los hechos que forman
parte de la investigación se remontan a
finales de 2010 tras unas elecciones
presidenciales muy reñidas las tensiones
entre paz voy utara aumentaron cuando la
comisión electoral de costa de marfil le
dio la victoria al asad para con el 54.1
de los votos algo respaldado por la onu
pero estos resultados fueron invalidados
al día siguiente por el consejo
constitucional que proclamó la victoria
de laurent gbagbo iniciando la inserción
del país en el caos por cinco meses los
partidarios de los dos bandos se
enfrentaron y la violencia derivada
acabó con la vida de más de tres mil
personas
no cedió ni un centímetro de terreno
junto a sus seguidores a gameplay wood
fue acusado de ordenar violaciones y
asesinatos de sus opositores en abril de
2011 fue detenido con la ayuda del
ejército francés y trasladado a la haya
donde se enfrentó a cuatro cargos por
crímenes de lesa humanidad los cuales
negó tras un juicio de tres años en el
que declararon 82 testigos las pruebas
con trabajo y bloque se consideraron
insuficientes y los dos hombres fueron
absueltos en enero de 2019 decisión
confirmada por la sala de apelación de
la cpi en 2021